على مدار التاريخ والى يومنا هذا عجز
الانسان عن مواجهه الزلازل اعطى الكوارث
الطبيعيه واكثرها شده لكن السؤال الذي
يتبادر الى الاذهان هل يمكن للانسان تسبب
في حدوث الزلازل والجواب غريب نوعا ما نعم
عن قصد او غير قصد يمكن للانسان ان يتسبب
في حدوث الزلازل وبعضها قد يكون مدمرا
خبراء في هذه الظاهره الطبيعيه كشفوا ان
هناك ممارسات بشريه يمكن ان تحدث بسببها
هزات ارضيه بقوه تصل الى ثمان درجات على
مقياس ريخته دراسه بحثيه نشرتها مجله
سيمولوجي كول ريسرجليترز حددت 730 موقعا
تسبب فيها النشاط البشري بحدوث زلازل على
مدار المئه وخمسين عاما الماضيه وقالت ان
التاثيرات الزلازل التي يسببها الانسان قد
تكون مشابهه لتلك التي تحدثها الطبيعه
النشاط البشري تسبب في حدوث زلازل تصل
قوتها الى 7.9 درجه وعدد الزلازل اخذ في
الارتفاع بشكل واضح في بعض مناطق العالم
وتماما كمزلازل التي تسببها الطبيعه من
المحتمل ان تكون الزلازل التي يسببها
الانسان خطيره ومميته ايضا
عمليات استخراج المعادن واحده من بين ابرز
المسببات لزلازل محتمله شركات التعدين
تحفر بشكل عميق تحت سطح الارض لاستخراج
ثرواتها الطبيعيه فتزيل في طريقها كثيرا
من الصخور والمواد الاخرى من طبقات الارض
الامر الذي قد يسبب عدم استقرار فيها
وبالتالي تصبح معرضه مستقبلا للانهيارات
والزلازل
عمليات بناء السدود لا تقل خطوره عن
سابقتها تاريخيا ادى بناء بعض السدود الى
حدوث مجموعه من اكبر واخطر الهزات الارضيه
التي تسبب فيها الانسان
عام 2008 لقي ما يقرب من 80 الف شخص
مصرعهم في مقاطعه بالصين نتيجه زلزال بلغت
قوته 7.9 درجه نتج وقتها بسبب ثقل 300
وعشرين مليون طن من المياه تم جمعها في
خزان زنجبو بعد بناء سد كبير فوق خط صدع
زلزالي
يمكن ان يؤدي ثقل وزن خزانات المياه
الكبيره الى حدوث زلازل بسبب تراكم
الاجهاد في الارض
اختبارات الاسلحه النوويه اخذت نصيبها في
قائمه المسببات ايضا فوفقا للعلماء في
مرصد لاموندو هارتي للارض بجامعه كولومبيا
تسبب اختبار كوريا الشماليه لقنبله نوويه
عام 2017
فيهازات ارتداديه استمرت لنحو ثمانيه اشهر
بعد الانفجار
اختبارات سابقه ناجتها الهند عام
وفجرت فيها ثلاث قنابل نوويه تحت الارض
تسببت ايضا في زلازل تجاوزت قوتها الخمس
درجات
عالمقياس ريختر رغم ان الانسان قد يتسبب
في افتعال زلازل لكن غالبا ما يتم اختيار
اماكن اقامه المشاريع الكبرى التي من
المحتمل ان تؤدي الى هزات ارضيه بعيدا عن
المناطق ذات النشاط الزلزالي المرتفع حيث
ان معظم الزلازل الطبيعيه تحدث على طول
خطوط الصدع المعروفه في اماكن تلاقي
الصفائح التكتونيه